[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من طهران واعلان
رسمي بالتواصل الى اتفاق لتبادل السجناء
مع واشنطن خلال الايام الماضيه ننتقل الى
واشنطن ورد سريع بنفي صحه ما صدر من
تصريحات في طهران بشان تبادل السجناء
ووصفها بكذبه اخرى الى الخرطوم وحاله ترقب
بعض اجتماعا بين البرهان وحماتي وكشف
القوى المدنيه عن نقاش مكثف لاختيار رئيس
للوزراء يقود حكومه مدنيه سياسيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
غموض بشان مقال اتفاق تبادل السجناء بين
طهران و واشنطن بعد حديث ايراني عن التوصل
الى صفقه واشنطن تنفي وتعتبر تصريحاتي
بشان الاتفاق كاذبه وتهران تؤكد تبادل
رسائل عبر وسطاء مع واشنطن لتحديث اتفاق
السنه الماضيه وتدعو الى عدم توظيف قضيه
السجناء سياسيا
مع استعداد الجيش الاوكراني لهجوم مضاد في
بخموت في مواجهه التقدم الروسي روسيا تقول
ان قوتها تكثف الهجوم على منطقه
خلاف يتصاعد بين واشنطن
لقتال في بخمود وطلب الدخائر وقضيه تفشير
نوتسرين
في ثالث هجوم على نابلس خلال اقل من
اسبوعين الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين مجموعه عارين الاسود تعلن
اشتباك ثلاثه من عناصرها مع وحده
اسرائيليه وتتوعد بالتالي لهم وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول ان العمليه قادتها وحده
النخبه
جولانياهو يتواعد بتصفيات كل ما يحاول
المسافه باسرائيل
في تداعيات اكبر افلاس لمصرف في الولايات
المتحده منذ 15 عاما واشنطن تقول انها
تسعى لتجنب تاثير انهيار بنك سيليكون ذلك
على بقيه النظام الوصفي لندن تحذر من خطر
جسيم على قطاع التكنولوجيا البريطاني
وصندوق النقد الدولي يراقب تداعيات انهيار
البنك على الاستقرار المالي العالمي
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات المحتمله للاجتماع
الذي جمع رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان
حميتي ورد فعل قوى اعلان الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي على هذا الاجتماع
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما
هي المسارات المحتمله للازمه في السودان
في ضوء التحركات الاخيره وقد جاءت النتيجه
على النحو الاتي
23% توقعوا نقل السلطه للمدنيين بينما صوت
37% لصالح خيار تعطل الاتفاق الايطالي اما
اربعون في المئه فذهبوا باتجاه امكانيه
حدوث خلافات داخل الجيش
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
مع مشهد احتجاجات يتسع دعوات للعصيان
المدني في اسرائيل في حاله تمرير خطه
للاصلاحات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد الله يهان ان بلاده توصلت الى اتفاقا
لتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن خلال الايام
الماضيه واضاف في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان
بلاده جاهزه من طرفها لتبادل السجناء وان
الولايات المتحده تقوم بالتنسيقيات
التقنيه وافقه تعبيره
تواصلنا مع الولايات المتحده خلال الايام
الماضيه الى اتفاق بشان مساله تبادل
السجناء واذا كانت كافه الامور جيده من
جانب الولايات المتحده اعتقد باننا سنشهد
خلال مده قصيره تبادل السجناء بين البلدين
هذا الملف انساني ومنذ مارس العام الماضي
وقعنا وثيقه مع واشنطن بشكل غير مباشر في
هذا الشان لكن ارضيه تنفيذ هذا التفاهم
باتت متاحه الان جاهزون من طرفنا والجانب
الامريكي يقوم بالتنسيق اللازم
وزير الخارجيات الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيان اكد ايضا استمرار تبادل الرسائل
مع الولايات المتحده في مساله اعاده تفعيل
الاتفاق النووي واضاف في مقابلات
تلفزيونيه ان الولايات المتحده لا تتحلى
بالشجاعه والجراه الكافيهتين لاتخاذ قرار
بهذا الشان
نعتقد انه يمكن التوصل الى اتفاق في ملف
رفع العقوبات رفع الاتهامات الموجهه ضد
ايران في الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
امر مهم ويعد من خطوطنا الحمراء شاهدنا
تقدما جيدا خلال زياره جروسي الى طهران
تبادل الرسائل بشكل غير مباشر مع الولايات
المتحده ما يزال مستمرا واكدت خلال
الرسائل للجانب الامريكي ان واشنطن لم
تتحلل لحد الان بالشجاعه والجرعه
الكافيتين لاتخاذ القرار بينما اثبت
الطهران ان لديها الاراده والشجاعه
اللازمتين وطرحت مواقفها المبنيه على
العقلانيه والمنطق على طاوله الحوار غير
المباشر
قالت الخارجيات الايرانيه ان رده الفعل
الامريكيه على اعلان وزير الخارجات
الايراني بشان تبادل السجناء مثيره
للاستغراب واضافت ان ايران توصلت لاتفاق
مكتوب وموقع من واشنطن لتبادل السجناء منذ
مارس 2022 لكنها لم تنفذه كما اشارت الى
تبادل طهران رسائل مع واشنطن في الاسابيع
الماضيه لتحديث اتفاق تبادل السجناء
واعتبرت الخارجيه الايرانيه ملف تبادل
السجناء قضيه انسانيه لا ينبغي توظيفها في
اللعب السياسيه حسب نص البيان
صفقات تبادل السجناء بين الولايات المتحده
وايران رغم قلتها فانها ترتبط غالبا بمسار
الاحداث التي ترافقها لاسيما ما يتعلق
بمفاوضات الملف النووي الايراني
في كل مره تعلن فيها صفقه تبادل اسرى بين
ايران والولايات المتحده تقرا التصريحات
بشانها بحذر ويلتفت الى سياق الاحداث في
واقع العلاقات المتازمه غالبا بين البلدين
ففي منتصف يناير من العام 2016 تمت الصفقه
الاولى بين الطرفين تبادلا فيها خمسه
سجناء امريكيين مقابل سبعه ايرانيين
يومها كان العالم حديث عهد بالاتفاق
النووي الذي اقره مجلس الامن في يوليو من
عام 2015
وتزامنت الصفقه مع لقاء في جنيف جامعه
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حينها محمد جواد
ظريف بنظيره الامريكي جون كيرينا لبحث رفع
العقوبات عن ايران وفق ما يقتضيه الاتفاق
النووي
ورغم ان اداره ترامب انسحبت من الاتفاق
بعد ذلك ونحت منحا اكثر تصلبا مع طهران
فانها اتمت في السابع من سبتمبر عام 2019
صفقه جديده توسطت فيها سويسرا وتم خلالها
تبادل سجنين بين الولايات المتحده وايران
كانت حينها اداره ترامب في مستهل للسنه
الاخيره من فتراتها لذلك غرد ترامب يومها
قائلا ان اطلاق سراح الامريكيين في الخارج
يمثل اهميه حيويه لادارته جاء الاعلان
الايراني هذه المره على لسان الخارجيه
حسين امير عبداللهيان بان طهران توصلت الى
اتفاق في مساله تبادل السجناء مع واشنطن
خلال الايام الماضيه ليفتح الملف مجددا
بعد مفاوضات سبقتها في عهد اداره بايدن لم
تسفر عن نتائج مهمه
ان بلاده جاهزه لتبادل السجناء وان
الولايات المتحده تعكف على اتخاذ الخطوات
التقنيه اللازمه لكن وصف المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد برايس تصريحات
الوزير الايراني بالكذبه القاسيه يلقي على
الملف بظلال من الريبه لا سيما وان
مفاوضات الملف النووي تراوح مكانها
تتهم اداره بايدن بانها لم تتحلى بالاراده
لاتخاذ قرار بشان المحادثات رغم اقرارها
بان تبادل الرسائل مع الولايات المتحده في
مساله رفع العقوبات مستمر
من طهران ينضم الينا الدكتور مصطفى خوش
جشم استاذ الدراسات الاعلاميه والسياسيه
في جامعه فارس كما ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الدكتور اندرو تابلر المستشار السابق في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ابدا معك
دكتور مصطفى دكتور مصطفى هل من اتفاق
لتبادل السجناء ام انها محاوله من قبل
طهران للضغط على الاداره الامريكيه
شكرا على الاستضافه مساء الخير بالنسبه
الى وزير الخارجيه الايراني لم يقل يوما
ان هذا الاتفاق
منتهى
ومؤكد من الجانبين قال انه مؤكد ومنتهم من
الجانب الايراني ايران مستعده له لتنفيذه
هذا ليس بجديد ايران عرض التبادل السجناء
سواء كان ذلك الاتفاق كاملا او جزئيا على
الدول الغربيه او فقط على الولايات
المتحده وذلك منذ سنوات ولكن للاسف فان
الولايات المتحده لا سيما اداره الرئيس
بايدن لطالما ربطت هذه الصفقه مع اعاده
احياء المفاوضات حول خطط العمل الشامله
المشتركه ان دوله قطر التي تنطلق منها
الجزيره ايضا تشارك في هذه المباحثات وفي
صفقه تبادل السجناء ليس في من المشاركه بل
المباحثات حول صفقه تبادل السجناء ووزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه طهران منذ شهر او
شهرين واعتبر رساله نقلها من الولايات
المتحده الولايات المتحده غير مستعده
للدخول في صفقه حول مصير سجناء لانها
تؤخرها من اجل اعاده احياء مباحثات خطه
العمل شامله المشاركه للاسف
طيب قبل مواصله هذا الحوار منوه الى الخبر
العاجل الوارد على شاشه الجزيره وهو في
نفس السياق الذي نتحدث عنه فاينانشيل
تايمز نقلت عن دبلوماسيا غربيا في طهران
قوله ان هناك زخم جديد لامكانيه تبادل
الاسرى بين ايران والولايات المتحده وتحول
هنا الى الدكتور اندرو تابلر دكتور اندرو
يعني الى اي مدى الظروف الحاليه تشبه
الظروف السابقه في عام 2016 وعام 2019
عندما تم توقيع اتفاقات لتبادل السجناء
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايران
هناك بعض الاشخاص الذين سيتم تحريرهم في
الايام المقبله لكن دكتور اندرو فاينانشل
تايمز تنقل عن دبلوماسيا غربيا كلام عن
زخم جديد فيما يتعلق بمساله تبادل السجناء
اعتقد ان هذا محتمل ولكننا لا نعلم تفاصيل
بعد انه خبر عاجل وصل للتو اذا كان هناك
تحرير للاسره فهذا امر ايجابي من شانه ان
يساعد السياق العام هل يحل مساله مفاوضات
حول
سوف يحل كل مشاكل ايران في المنطقه لا
طبعا هناك تطورات بارزه
تتعلق باعاده التسانا في العلاقات بين
ايران والسعوديه التي يمكن ان تفتح قوه
امام المزيد من الفرص الدبلوماسيه ما
يعنيه ذلك عمليا في مناطق مثل العراق
وسوريا هو فعلا ما يهم ولكن يجب ان ننتظر
لنرى
اعود اليك دكتور مصطفى دكتور مصطفى وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه تحدث عن خطوات تقنيه
ما هو المقصود بخطوات تقنيه يعني بماذا
تربط ايران مساله الافراج عن سجناء مقابل
ماذا تربط ذلك
لقد عرضت ايران منذ سنوات
استعدادها لصفقه تبادل الاسرى لكافه
المواطنين الغربيين المسجونين في مقابل
تحرير الاسرى الايرانيين في دول الغربيه
او اتفاق جزئي
يقتصر على المعتل الامريكيين المجرونين في
ايران مقابل الكثير من الايرانيين الذين
سجنوا في الولايات المتحده لمبررات وهي
وحجج غير مقنعه مثل مساعده دولتهم مثلا من
خلال
مستحضرات
مثل الادويه
وهناك حجره تقول انه انتهكوا العقوبات ان
جزءا من هذا الاتفاقات وهذا الصفقات هي
تحرير اصول ايرانيه
ومبيعات ايرانيه لنفط الخام لكوريا
بمليارات الدولارات الولايات المتحده
تحاول ان تستمر بالضغط ايران للضغط عليها
من اجل الدخول في مفاوضات نوويه هم يؤجلون
هذا الجزء من الاتفاق الذي كان يجب ان
يحصل بتحرير الاصول الى احدى البنوك
الخليجيه اتحدث عن الاموال الايرانيه
وايران يمكن ان تستعيد هذه الاصول من خلال
هذا البنك الخليجي
ولكن
المكتب مراقبه الاصول الاجنبيه الامريكي
الاوفاك لم يصدر اثنان لايران لكي تستعيد
اصولها من هذا البنك الخليجي الذي ليس في
قطر بل في دوله خليجيه اخرى ولكن اذا
تحررت هذه الاصول اذا سالنا حكومه سيول في
كوريا الجنوبيه ستقول انها لم تتلقى اي
اذا من الولايات المتحده لتحرير اي اصول
ولم يتم الاتصال بها اطلاقا
هنا مره اخرى المشكله هي ان الولايات
المتحده تدعي الغباء لانها لا تريد ان
تمضي قدما بهذا الصفقه الا اذا
اسمع تعليق من الدكتور اندرو تابلر على
هذه النقطه دكتور اندرو وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه تحدث عن رسائل متبادله مع
الجانب الامريكي وهذا ما تنفيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او على الاقل لا تؤكد
ذلك كيف نفهم الموقف الامريكي
اذا لن تؤكد تبادل هذه الرسائل قبل ان
يعلن ذلك هذا امر شائع هذا اولا ثانيا
سيكون من الصعب
بالنسبه الى اي مفاوضات مع الولايات
المتحده الا تشمل الاتفاق النوويه هذا
برايي كما اسلف زميلي
ولكننا ببساطه لا نعلم اعتقد انه قريبا
سنعلم هناك الكثير الامور التي تستاجد مثل
استئناف العلاقات بين طهران والرياض وهذا
قد ساعد في ضخ بعد الزخم في هذا السياق
وهذا لا هذا لا يغير اي موقف استراتيجي
حتى الان نحن لا نعرفها بالتالي انا احثكم
واحط المشاهدين على متابعه الملف عن كثب
شكرا لك الدكتور اندرو تابلور المستشار
السابق في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي كنت
معنا من واشنطن والشكر موصول للدكتور
مصطفى خوش جشم واستاذ الدراسات الاعلاميه
والسياسيه في جامعه فارس من طهران
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله ريا نوفاستن روسيه ان ميليشيا
فاجنر ان ميليشيا فاجنر سيطرت على مواقع
جديده وصفتها بالمهمه داخل المنطقه
الصناعيه وسط مدينه باخمت واضافت الوكاله
نقلا عن مصدر موال لروسيا في اقليم دومباس
ان وحدات فاجنر سيطرت على مواقع داخل مصنع
معالجه الصلب على الضفه الغربيه لنهر
بخمودكا ما يسهل السيطره على المنطقه
الصناعيه ويجعلها منطلقا لهجمات ميليشيا
فاجنر على ما تبقى من احياء يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني كما قال موقع ريبار
العسكري ان سلاح الجو الروسي شنا ضربات
مكثفه على مواقع الجيش الاوكراني وسط
باخموت وفي بلدات مجاوره
سجلات داخل اوكرانيا ومع حلفائها بشان
جدوى معركه باخموت نشر المركز الاعلامي
العسكري لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بيانا
يشرح فيها اهميه الدفاع عن باخموت معتبرا
ان القوات الروسيه تركز عملياتها على
منطقه دونياسك بهدف الوصول الى الحدود
الاداريه لمنطقه دونيس ولوغانسك وزياده
كثافه العمليات الهجوميه في اتجاهات
الايمان ومارينكا واشار البيان الى ان
الدفاع عن باخموت يساهم في ربط القوات
الرئيسيه والاحتياطات الكبيره للروس في
مكان واحد وتكبيدها خسائر كبيره واجبار
القوات الروسيه على اجراء عمليات تناوب
متكرره للوحدات المشاركه في العمليات
الهجوميه ما يساهم في اضاعه الوقت
والموارد
واسقاطهم امكاناتهم الهجوميه وقدراتهم في
اتجاهات اخرى وفق البيان
وعلى جبهه سوليدار سيفرياس كاع اعلنت
القوات الاوكرانيه ان وحدات تابعه لها
اشتبكت مع مسلحين من ميليشيات وقالت انها
تمكنت من اسرع احد المسلحين وقتل اخر
ونشرت القوات الاوكرانيه مقاطع فيديو
وقالت انها من موقع الاشتباك الذي اكدت
انه اندلع بعد محاوله مسلحين من فاجنر
الاقتراب من مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في
المنطقه
وفي الجنوب اعلنت سلطات خرسون المواليه
لروسيا مقتله مدني في قصف مدفعي اوكراني
استهدف مدينه نوفويا كخوفكا على الضفه
اليسرى لنهر دينيبر جنوبي اوكرانيا وقالت
ان القوات الاوكرانيه باتت تقصف الاراضي
الواقعه على الضفه اليسرى من النهر بشكل
متواصل باستخدام اسلحه غربيه الصنع واكدت
ان القذف المدفعي الاخير استهدف مناطق
سكنيه وسط نوفويا كخوفكا وحي سكول في وسط
المدينه
في حين قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات
الجنوب الاوكرانيه نتاليا هومينيا كان
القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل بشكل يومي لدفع
القوات الروسيه الى تراجع في الضفه اليسرى
من خرسون وذلك عبر تكثيف القصف المدفعي
الذي يستهدف هذه القوات اتهمت القوات
الروسيه بنشر الاسلحه بين منازل السكان
هناك وبترهيبها
تتخذ قوات العدو مواقع لها على مسافه
قريبه من الضفه اليسرى ما يتيح لها قصف
مواقع قوتنا على الضفه اليمنى لكن قوتنا
تعمل بشكل متواصل لضرب هذه القوات
بالمدفعيه ومحاوله دفعها للتراجع الى
مسافه ما بعد 20 كيلو مترا على الاقل
القوات الروسيه تقصف بلدات في الاراضي
المحتله بالهاون وترهب السكان وتقول انها
ضربات من القوات الاوكرانيه
نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مصادر مطلعه ان
هناك خلافات متزايده وراء الكواليس بين
الولايات المتحده واوكرانيا بشان اهداف
الحرب وكيفيه وموعد نهايه الصراع العسكري
مع روسيا
على وقع مواجهات بخموت اطول المعارك
واشدها منذ اندلاع الحرب على اوكرانيا قبل
عام ونيف تكشفت اكثر حقيقه الخلافات بين
الولايات المتحده والقياده الاوكرانيه
فنقلا عن مسؤولين في اداره بايدن قالت
صحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه ان كيف تجاهلت
نصائح واشنطن العسكريه وان الخلاف بين
العاصمتين يتصاعد في الكواليس بشان اهداف
الحرب وكيفيه وموعد نهايه الصراع العسكري
مع روسيا كما لا يبدي الجانب الامريكي
رضاه عن مجريات معركه باخموت ويعتبرها
استنزافا لا اكثر من اجل مدينه غير مهمه
من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
ووفق الصحيفه فان تخريب خط انابيب نورد
ستريم بات من عوامل التوتر الجديده ايضا
بعد توصل المخابرات الامريكيه الى استنتاج
مفاده ان مجموعه مؤيده لاوكرانيا كانت
مسؤوله عن الحادث ويضاف الى ذلك رفض
واشنطن خطط لاستعاده شبه جزيره القرم التي
ترسخ فيها الوجود الروسي منذ نحو عشر
سنوات
وتعكس هذه التسريبات ارتدادات الحرب على
كل الاطراف بعد عام من اندلاعها وهي اذ
تتزامن مع تقدم ميداني لميليشيا فاجنر
وسيطرتها على اجزاء واسعه من بخموت فقد
تعني مزيدا من المصاعب للجانب الاوكراني
ميدانيا وسياسيا ذلك ما قد يفسر مصارعه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه الى اصدار بيان
يشرح اهميه الدفاع عن بخموت مخاطبا
الامريكيين ضمنا اعتبر البيان ان القوات
الروسيه تعزز عملياتها في المنطقه للوصول
الى الحدود الاداريه لمنطقتي
وان المقاومه الاوكرانيه وفق البيان هدفها
تكبيد الروس خسائر كبيره وافقادهم
امكاناتهم الهجوميه وقدراتهم على التقدم
في اتجاهات اخرى
ايا يكن الامر فقد سبق لمسؤولين امريكيين
ان ابدوا تحفظات على اندفاع اوكرانيا وسقف
تطلعاتها العالي فوزير الدفاع لويد اوستن
اعتبرت دفاعا بخموت مجرد عمل رمزي اكثر من
كونه قيمه استراتيجيه كما اعرب البنتاغون
باستمرار عن شكوكه فيما اذا كان الجيش
الاوكراني قادرا على دفع القوات الروسيه
الى خارج الحدود ناهيك عن استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم
انضموا الينا من
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق كما
ينضم الينا من فيرجينيا على ريكورد مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي وابدا
معك سيد اوليكسي سيد اوليكسي ما حقيقه
وجود خلافات او نقاط توتر متزايده في
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده واوكرانيا
انا لا اعتقد ان هناك اي توتر او نزاع
هناك بعض النقاط التي ربما لا يتم التواصل
الاتفاق حولها ولكننا فعلا نحن نشهد على
مستوى من التعاون بين الدولتين انا لا
اعتقد ان هناك اي مؤشر على وجود اي نزاع
او حتى بدايه نزاع ما هي هذه النقاط سيد
اوليكس التي اشرت اليها
اولا
وعلى المستوى الاستراتيجي هناك سوء فهم او
انا اصفه بانه اختلاف في
وجهات النظر داخل الطيف السياسي الامريكان
نشط سياسي الامريكي داخل الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه الى
الدعم
الثنائي الامريكي هناك ايضا فرق واضح
بين
او تصور كيف يجب على الجيش الاوكراني ان
يكون عليه هو هذه كلها مسائلها علاقه
بجوانب فنيه وتنفيذيه على الارض
ما طبيعه الخلافات وحدود هذه الخلافات هل
هي اختلافات في وجهات النظر ام انها نقاط
اختلاف تتزايد ويمكن ان تصل الى اختلافات
حقيقيه
انا لا اعتقد انها سوف تصل الى مستوى
خلافات والنزاعات كان هناك اختلافات
تباينات منذ البدايه حول كيف يجب ان تقود
اوكرانيا الحرب وما يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان توفره لها من تجهيزاتهم عادات دعونا لا
ننسى ان اوكرانيا ارادت الدبابات مباشره
ولكننا ارسلنا لها الدبابات بعد سنه
لاننا في الاساس لم نشا ان نصاعد الموضوع
حتى يصير نزاعا مباشره مع روسيا ولاسيما
ان روسيا تحدثت عن امكانيه استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
وبالتالي صار لدينا الان
عدم اتفاق بالنسبه الى توفير الطائرات
المتحده لا تريد توفيرها ولكن هناك اشخاص
واطراف وجهت داخل الولايات المتحده مثل
الجنرال كلارك الذي كان قائدا حلف شمال
اطلسي يريد ان يوفرها بالنسبه الى في
البدايه رفضنا ومن ثم ومع تطور
المشهد الحرب وظهور الحاجه الملحه
لاوكرانيا لتتصدى لروسيا
وفرناها لها اذا استمرت الحرب كما حصل
لسنه اخرى سوف تحصل اوكرانيا على الطائرات
في الحقيقه نحن في صدد تدريب الطيارين في
حال كنا سوف نوفر هذه الطائرات من طراز اف
16 سيد لاريا ولكن في الفتره الاخيره
بدانا نسمع اصوات متزايده داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقول بان الدعم لا يمكن
ان يكون مطلقا
في الحقيقه هكذا تعمل ديمقراطيتنا تختلف
جهه النظر البعض لا يريد توفير اي دعم
ونتحدث هنا عن جانب من الجمهوريين هناك
بعض الديمقراطيين التقدميين الذين يفضلون
ان نركز على مشاكلنا الداخليه مثل موضوع
رعايه صحيه ولكن بصوره اساسيه هناك توافق
نصبي حتى الان مفاده ان نوفر لاوكرانيا ما
تحتاج اليه حتى تمنع روسيا من التحكم
بمناطق في البلاد روسيا كانت تسيطر على
20% في احدى الفترات هو انخفضت سيطرته الى
17% طبعا بالنسبه الى موضوع بخموت فهو
يثير الكثير من الجدال للكثير من
العسكريين الذين لا يعطونا كثيرا الاهميه
ولكن بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا هذا مهم على
المساواه النفسي والم عنوي لان ذلك يعني
ان روسيا سوف تمنع من السيطره عن المزيد
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تقييمكم للدعم الامريكي هل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقدم ما يسمح لاوكرانيا
بالنصر ام فقط بالصمود
اولا نحن ممتنون كثيرا لدعم الامريكي ليس
فقط الامريكي بل ايضا لدعم اكثر من 50
شريكا وفروا الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا اما
تقييمنا اذا كان ذلك كافيا طبعا هو ليس
كافيا ولكن هي ليست مساله الاستمرار
والصمود فقط
بدون الفوز
نحن بين
النقطتين نحن بحشرنا المزيد طبعا وبصوره
عامه انا اعتقد
ان هذا
حتى الان هو كافن بالنظر الى القيود التي
يفرضها
شركائنا وحلفاؤنا سواء كانت اقتصاديه او
سياسيه او غيرها طيب
ذكرت نقاط محدده فيما يتعلق بباخ موت
وايضا فيما يتعلق باستعاده جزيره القرم
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تشكل هذه النقاط او
الاختلاف مع الولايات المتحده تاثير على
المعركه على الارض
يجب ان نفصل بين هذه القضايا المختلفه اذا
كنا نتحدث عن بخموت طبعا هناك الكثير من
الاسئله المطروحه داخل وخارج اوكرانيا
واعتقد ان على القيادات العسكريه
وحدها التي لديها الصوره كامله
وتمتلك الحل الافضل
وبالتالي هناك هدف عسكري وهناك عسكريه لما
يحصل اما بالنسبه الى موضوع القرم فهو
مختلف هو موضوع استراتيجي وتختلف المواقف
بين الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا حول كيفيه تحرير شبه جزيره
القرم
ومن ابرز العراقيل التي لا تزال تمنع
حلفائنا من التحرك هو ان القرم هو خط احمر
في حال اجتازته اوكرانيا سوف ترد روسيا
بطريقه فظيعه مثل الاسلحه النوويه شكرا لك
اوليك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
السابق كنت معنا
بمساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
وكبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي
من فيرجينيا
[موسيقى]
قتل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثلاثه
فلسطينيين جنوب غربي نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
وقال جيش الاحتلال لان قوته اطلقت النار
على مجموعه مسلحه قربا حاجز ساره العسكري
وقد نانت فصائل فلسطينيه جريمه الاحتلال
بينما تبنت مجموعه عارينا الاسود الشهداء
الثلاثه وتوعدت بالتالي لهما من جهته هدد
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
بقتل كل ما يحاول المسافه باسرائيل او
الحاق الضرر بها
في كمين نصبه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بشقه في بنايه قيد الانشاء قرب حاجز صرا
العسكريه جنوب غربي نابلس كان اربعه من
مقاتلي مجموعات عارين الاسود في مرمى
نيران الاحتلال خلال اشتباك المسلح ادى
الى استشهاد ثلاثه منهم واعتقال الرابع
ومصادره قطع سلاح وذخيره
كنا نايمين يعني فجاه سمعنا صوت اطلاق نار
كان كثيف جدا يعني من قبل جنود
الاسرائيليه طلعنا على الشباك نشوف شو فيه
يعني لقينا سياره صافيه موجوده هون
والثلاث شباب كانوا على الارض
الحداد العم مخيم على اجواء المدينه
واحيائها بينما عم اضراب تجاري جزئي في
مركزها حزنا على سقوط الشهداء الثلاثه
برصاص الاحتلال فصائل فلسطينيه دانت جريمه
الاحتلال الجديده واعتبرت انها تاتي في
سياق الحرب الشامله والمفتوحه التي تشنها
حكومه الاحتلال بحق الفلسطينيين ومقاومتهم
بدورها تبنت مجموعات عارين الاسود شهدائها
الثلاثه وتوعدت الاحتلال بالثار لهم امام
هذا الوعيد هدد رئيس حكومه الاحتلال
العائد من زياره رسميه لروما في جلسه
حكومته الاسبوعيه بقتل من يحاول المس
بمواطن اسرائيل
من اجل الشفاء العاجل لجرحى العمليه
القاسيه امس الاول في تل ابيب واؤدي
التحيه للمتطوع وللمقاتلين الذين قضوا على
المخرب لقد اوعزنا بهدم منزله واعتقلنا
والده مع متورطين اخرين في هذه العمليه
القاسيه
سنحاكمهم وننزل بهم العقاب مثل ما نرى فان
قواتنا تعمل على مدار الساعه ضد كل ما
يريد المساس بحياتنا والمبدا بسيط جدا فمن
يحاول الاضرار بنا فدمه في راسه
[موسيقى]
وباستشهاد الشبان الثلاثه ترتفع حصيله
الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام
الى اكثر من 80 شهيدا في جميع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بين وعيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بثار لشهدائها وتهديد حكومه الاحتلال
بالقضاء عليها يزداد الوضع توترا على نحو
يجعله على حافه الانفجار على جميع
المستويات سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره نابلس
فلسطين
ابرزوا الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه لطفه
الغربيه هذا العام مورد الفلسطيني عليها
في العرض التالي
اكبر الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه للضفه
الغربيه المحتله منذ مطلع العام 2023 كان
من نصيب مدينه جنين ومخيمها فجر السادس
والعشرين من يناير اسفر حينها عن استشهاد
عشره فلسطينيين بينهم سيده مسنه بعدها
بيوم واحد الشاب الفلسطيني خيري علقم ينفذ
هجوم المسلحا قرب كنيس يهودي على اطراف
القدس المحتله يسفر عن مقتل سبعه
اسرائيليين في السادس من فبراير الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقتحموا مخيم عقبه
جبر في مدينه اريحا شرقيه الضفه الغربيه
ويقتل خمسه فلسطينيين بعدها باربعه ايام
قتل مستوطنان اسرائيليان واصيب خمسه اخرون
في عمليه دهس نفذها فلسطينيون بسيارته
قربا مستوطنه راموت شماليه القدس المحتله
في الثاني والعشرين من فبراير اقتحام
اسرائيليون واسع لمدينه نابلس يسفر عن
مقتل احد عشر فلسطينيا واصابه نحو 100
اخرين بعدها باربعه ايام اسير فلسطيني
محرر يفتح النار على سياره اسرائيليه
ويقتل مستوطنين اثنين في بلده حواره
جنوبيه نابلس وقد اعقب العمليه هجوم واسع
للمستوطنين على بلده حواره والقرى التي
حولها ما ادى الى استشهاد فلسطيني وحرق
عشرات المنازل والسيارات في السابع من
مارس استشهد سته فلسطينيين واصيب اخرون في
اقتحام اعداد كبيره من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي معززه بقوات خاصه مدينه جنين
ومخيمها ولم يكد يمر يومان على هذا
الاقتحام حتى اغتالت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه
ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين في بلده جبع جنوبيه
جنين
بعدها بيوم واحد اصيب خمسه اسرائيليين في
عمليه اطلاق النار نفذها شاب فلسطيني في
شارع ديزنوف وسطات الابيب
[موسيقى]
انضموا الينا من رام الله الدكتور رهاني
المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور هاني
التصعيد الاسرائيلي متواصل الى اين يمكن
ان تصل الامور
في هذا الشهر يكون قد مر عام كامل على
معركه كاسر الامواج وهي الخطه التي وضعتها
قوات الاحتلال للقضاء على المقاومه خاصه
القضاء على الجيل الجديد من المقاومه سواء
الذي يعبر عن نفسه بالمقاومه الفرديه او
من خلال الكتائب ولكن نحن الان ابعد ما
نكون عن تحقيق الهدف الاسرائيلي فلا تزال
العمليات الفلسطينيه مستمره سواء بشكل
العمليات العسكريه او باشكال لا حصر لها
من المقاومه التي تصل الى المئات من
العمليات مما يدل على ان الشعب الفلسطيني
مستعد لمواجهه العدوان والجرائم
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هناك سيناريو
التصعيد هو السيناريو الاقوى من جهه قوات
الاحتلال والحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
ترى انها قادره على الحسم وقادره على
ايقاع خسائر كبرى وكسر اراده الفلسطينيين
وترويعهم وانها ستحقق مع اجهزه الانقباض
الاسرائيليه عن تحقيقه في ظل هذه المواقف
وفي ظل هذا التصعيد هل يمكن ان نصل الى
مواجهه شامله
نعم استمرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالتصعيد
وحاجتها الى التصعيد خاصه في ظل تفاقم
الازمه الداخليه داخل اسرائيل والتي تنذر
بالسبور وعظائم الامور المهرب
الاساسي الذي يمكن ان تلجا اليه الحكومه
هو التصعيد ضد الفلسطينيين حتى يتم يعني
الحصول على اجماع اسرائيلي لان المعارضه
الاسرائيليه لا تختلف مع الحكومه فيما
تفعله مع الفلسطينيين الخلافات هي على
قضايا تتعلق بطبيعه الدوله وهو اليهودي
والديمقراطيه وما شابه ذلك اما بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين هناك اجماع وهذا يدل عليه ان
القوانين العنصريه التي اقرت ضد
الفلسطينيين صوت لصالحها الكثير من اعضاء
الكنيست من المعارضه نعم يمكن ان يكون
هناك تصعيد وانفجار شامل خاصه نحن على
ابواب شهر رمضان الفضيل وعيد الفصح وبعد
ذلك مسيره الاعلام وسط يعني دعوات
اسرائيليه لاقتحام المسجد الاقصى ووسط
تصميم الحكومه على محاوله كسر اراده الشعب
ما هي الخيارات امام الجانب الفلسطيني
اعتقد لا يوجد خيار الا الصمود والمقاومه
وضروره الارتقاء الى مستوى الوحده
الميدانيه التي تتجسد في المدن وخاصه في
جنين ونابلس وتحويلها ايضا الى وحده
سياسيه لان استمرار الانقسام البغيض
يستنزف طاقات الشعب الفلسطيني ويمنع
امكانيه تصاعد المقاومه ويمنع تحقيق
انجازات سياسيه لذلك مهم ان تستمر
للمقاومه وان يتم ردع المستوطنين وقوات
الاحتلال لانهم اذا لم يواجهوا بردود
فلسطينيه هذا سيفتح شهيتهم الى تصعيد اكبر
لذلك عندما يدفع ثمن سيفكر اكثر ولكن يجب
تنظيم هذه العمليه بحيث لا تكون بشكل عفوي
او تلقائي يجب ان تكون تخضع لقياده واحده
استراتيجيه واحده وهذا يستدعي تشكيل قياده
وطنيه واحده ميدانيه على طريق تشكيل قياده
سياسيه واحده وان احتاجت المزيد من الوقت
لان القياده لا تريد هذه الوحده وهناك
ايضا مطالب فئويه للفصائل تجعل هذه الوحده
متعذره من الان وحتى اشعار اخر هذه المصري
مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه كنت معنا مره مره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق اهود
باراك الى العصيان المدني في اسرائيل في
حاله تمريره خطه التعديلات القضائيه اود
عبارات في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه رؤساء المؤسسات الامنيه الى
الوقوف ضد هذه الخطه
هو هجوم على روح ديمقراطيتنا وعلى استقلال
المحكمه العليا وقيم اعلان الاستقلال
بمجرد ان تستخدم الحكومه ادوات
الديمقراطيه لتدميرها من الداخل وتتصرف
بشكل غير شرعي فانه ليس من حق المواطنين
اللجوء الى العصيان المدني فحسب بل من
واجبهم ولكن يجب ان يكون عصيا غير عنيف قد
يكون امامنا اسبوعان او ثلاثه اسابيع قبل
الانتهاء من هذا التشريع وامنوا ان يقف
ضده رئيس جهاز المخابرات ورئيس الشرطه
ورئيس هيئه اركان الدفاع الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جانتيالن ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن تعمل
مع المسؤولين في القطاع المصرفي لايجاد
الحل المناسب لازمه بنك سيليكون فعلي بعد
انهياره يوم الجمعه الماضيه فيما اعلن
رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكارتي انه تحدث
مع مسؤولين في اداره بايدن بشان الازمه
قائلا ان لديهم الادوات اللازمه للتعامل
مع الوضع الحالي
صوره ذكرت باوائل ايام الازمه الماليه عام
2008 ومخاوف من ان يكون انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي بدايه لازمه اوسع مودعون
يتجمعون خارج فروعه في سيليكون فالي غير
قادرين على الوصول الى اموالهم بعد ان
اقدمت سلطات ولايه كاليفورنيا على اغلاقه
انهيار البنك خلف حاله من القلق ايذاء
مستقبل قطاع التكنولوجيا خصوصا انه المقرض
الاكبر للشركات الناشئه في ذلك المجال
ويعد ايضا البنك السادس عشر على مستوى
الولايات المتحده من حيث حجم الاصول وبعد
اعلان الانهيار وضعت المؤسسه الفيدراليه
للتامين على الودائع وصيا عليه حيث سيسمح
لعملاء البنك بسحب مبلغ اقصاه 250 الف
دولار من ودائعهم وهو المبلغ الذي عاده ما
تضمنه المؤسسه
الاقتصاد الامريكي يقوم على نظام مصرفي
امن وسليم يمكنه توفير الاحتياجات
الائتمانيه لاسرنا وشركاتنا عندما يفشل
بنك مثل بنك سيليكون فالي الذي لديه ودائع
بمليارات الدولارات فمن الواضح ان ذلك
مصدر قلق نعمل مع المسؤولين في القطاع
المصرفي لتصميم السياسات المناسبه لمعالجه
هذا الوضع
اصرار الاداره الامريكيه على مرونه النظام
المصرفي ياتي في ظل تساؤلات عما اذا كانت
سياسه رفع اسعار الفائده الامريكيه التي
اتبعها البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لمواجهه
التضخم قد ساهمت في ابطاء وتيره الاستثمار
في قطاع التكنولوجيا وان نقص راس المال
الاستثماري في ذلك القطاع فرض على الشركات
الناشئه تخفيض ودائعها في البنك
تحدثت مع مسؤولين في الاداره مثل رئيس
مجلس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي ووزيره الخزانه
ولديهما الادوات اللازمه للتعامل مع الوضع
الحالي كما انهما يدركان خطورته هذا البنك
فريد من نوعه نظرا لعملائه والاصول التي
يتوفر عليها
وكان بنك سيليكون فالي قد انشئ عام ثلاثه
وثمانين في وقت لم تتجرا بنوك تقليديه على
تمويل مشاريع شركات ناشئه افلاسو بنكي
سيليكون فالي هو الاول منذ ازمه عام 2008
كما انه ثاني اكبر انهيار لمصرف في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده انهياره المفاجئ يطرح
تساؤلات بشان وضع قطاع تكنولوجيا ومستقبله
وعن سلامه وصحتي النظام المصرفي الامريكي
بسبب كويك الجزيره واشنطن
حاله من الذعر سادت في اوساط المصارف
الامريكيه بعد اغلاقه بنك سيليكون فالي في
اكبر افلاس لمصرف في الولايات المتحده منذ
عام 2008 ما الذي نعرفه عن هذا البنك يبلغ
عمر البنك
واربعين عاما وينظر اليه على انه قوه
استقرار بصفته بنكا منظما كبيرا لم يكن
مصرف سيليكون فالي معروفا لدى جمهور واسع
اذا تخصص في تمويل الشركات الناشئه واصبح
البنك الامريكي السادس عشر في حجم الاصول
وفي النهايه العام الماضي كانت لديه اصول
بقيمه 200
وتسعه مليارات دولار وودائع تبلغ اكثر من
مئه وخمسه وسبعين مليارا وكان بنكو
سيليكون فالي يتفاخر بان قرابه نصف شركات
التكنولوجيا وعلوم الحياه التي يمولها
مستثمرون امريكيون هي من زبائنه وستسمح
التصفيه المنظمه للمصرف بان يستعيد كل
زبون ما يصل الى 250 الف دولار وهو المبلغ
الاقصى الذي تضمنه او تضمنه المؤسس
الفيدراليه لتامين الودائع ولا يمثل زوال
بنك سيليكون فالي اكبر افلاس مصرفي منذ
2008 فحسب بل يشكل ايضا ثاني اكبر فشل
لبنك للتجزئه في الولايات المتحده وهنا
السؤال عن التداعيات المحتمله ورد الفعل
الحكومي وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانتيال
اجتمعت بعدد من منظمي القطاع المالي واكدت
لهم ان لديها ثقه كامله في قدرتهم على
اتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه وشددت على ان
القطاع المصرفي لا يزال مرنا وقبل ساعات
قالت يلن ان الحكومه الامريكيه تريد تجنب
تاثير افلاس السيليكون فالي على بقيه
النظام المصرفي لكنها استبعدت امكانيه
انقاذ المؤسسه عبر ضخ اموال عامه فيها
ماذا عن المخاطر تسبب
الافلاس افلاس البنك في تجميد عشره
مليارات الدولارات التي اودعتها فيه شركات
ناشئه وصناديق واسهم خاصه ما اثار الخشيه
من حصول صدمه في القطاع التكنولوجي وبحسب
التقرير السنوي لبنك سيليكون فالي فان
الجزء غير المؤمن من الودائع يصل الى نحو
96% من القيمه الاجماليه للودائع البالغه
173 مليار دولار
ويحذر خبراء من انه في غضون شهر او اثنين
سيكون قد اختفى جيل من الشركات الناشئه
وان سنوات من الابتكار الامريكي باتت على
المحكمه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نيويورك ريتشارد وولف استاذ الاقتصاد
بجامعه مسدس جوسيست اهلا بك دكتور ريتشارد
دكتور ريتشارد ما تاثير وتداعيات افلاس
بنك سيليكون فالي بدايه على النظام
المصرفي الامريكي هل من تداعيات لذلك
التاثير الابرز والاهم
لهذا الحدث هو انه بين اهداف الارباح
الخاصه
للبنك مؤسسه وفشل الحكومه في توفير
التنظيمات واللوائح لتنظيم عمل البنك هذان
العنصران اجتمع من اجل
التوصل الى هذه الكارثه اتحدث عن كارثه
بكل جديه نحن لا نعلم كم من المصارف
الاخرى التي تجد في وضع مماثل لا تحصل على
الودائع التي كانت تاملها وكذلك قد اشترت
عددا من السندات وغيرها التي فقدت قيمتها
هناك الكثير من البنوك ويجب ان احاول ان
نتبين ايام منها لانه مسموح لها ان تخفي
هذه المعلومات ضمن ظروف مختلفه وهذا ما
فعله
سيليكون ولم يكن اي هيئه تنظيميه كشفت
الموضوع من اجل ضمان التحقيق فيها
وحمايه المذيعين الذين سيتاثرون الان
بالتالي اعتبروا انه امر تراجيدي فعلا
لانه في
سيد ريتشارد عذرا على المقاطعه تتحدث عن
كارثه الى اي مدى يشبه ما يجري اليوم او
ما جرى مع سيليكون فالي بما جرى في عام
هذا صحيح فعلا انه مثال اخر عما حصل
وعدونا بعد
2009 ان هناك الكثير من الاصلاحات الجديده
من كافه الانواع
وتنظيمات الجديده التي من شانها ان تمنع
حصول وتكرار هكذا اسم هذا ما قاله لنا في
ركود العام
1930 لم يحصل ذلك في ذلك الوقت ولم يحصل
الان وسوف نمر بنفس الفتره العصيبه مره
اخرى يعني هل تتوقعون الاسود الاسوا سيد
ريتشارد
هناك حاجه اذا الى تغيير النظام ويبدو ان
هناك ما يعرقل تغييره تتوقعون الاسوا
ق لهذه المرحله انا لا اتوقع الاسوا بل
اتوقع نوعا من المراره من الغضب منذ
اسابيع قليله وجهنا مشكله مماثله
حديدي او مؤسسه سكك حديديه خاصه لم تمضي
او لم تنفق ما يكفي من المال على حمايه
السلامه وحصلت اضرار كبيره القصه تتكرر
مؤسسه من القطاع الخاص بدون تنظيم كافن
ونحن نقلق بشان عمق هذه الازمه هل فعلا
سوف نعيش انهيارا اخر ربما حتى نتعلم في
نهايه المطاف الدروس شكرا لك سيد ريتشارد
وولف استاذ الاقتصاد بجامعات ماساتشوسات
[موسيقى]
مره من هنا وحديثنا عن الاعصار فريدي
الاستوائي الذي ضرب وسط موزمبيق اليوم بعد
وصوله الى اليابسه للمره الثانيه خلال شهر
وتخطيه المعدلات القياسيه لمده وقوه
العواصف المداريه في النصف الجنوبي للكره
الارضيه بحسب منظمات غير حكوميه تسبب
الاعصار في تدمير واضرار في كثير من
المنازل خصوصا في مدينه كيلي ماني
الساحليه ورجحت المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه التابعه للامم المتحده ان يصبح
الاحصار فريدي الذي نشا قباله الساحل
الاستراليه الشماليه الغربي وتحول الى
عاصفه تحمل اسما في السادس من شباط فبراير
اطول اعصار استوائي من حيث المده يقول
علماء ان تغير المناخ يتسبب في زياده قوه
ومده الاعاصير اشياء كثيره تتغير حولنا
وبينما هذه الاشياء نتمنى السلامه للجميع
دمتم بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]